well as concerns over the uptick in
covid cases in southern nevada health
officials trying to prevent history from
repeating itself
we thank you for staying with us i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
face mass use returned as you know last
week here in clark county
christian casadas explains how one
doctor says we are not
out of the woods yet so the common mode
of transmission remains
uh person to person transmission of
covet 19.
that's according to dr apiksha desai
from optum nevada
who tells us one of the most common ways
to get the virus
is being exposed to someone who has
coveted regardless if they show any
symptoms
so i believe that if we are going to be
indoors in a public public and crowded
place
where we are unaware of the vaccination
status of other people
it still makes sense to continue to wear
a mask
and when possible continue to maintain
the social distancing
as las vegas brings back more
entertainment sports and even dining
dr desai says people can get carried
away and will drop their guard
even if they're vaccinated it doesn't
mean a hundred percent
like i said despite how good they are
they're not 100 productive you can still
get covered by
19 but your chances of getting very sick
or ending up in the hospital
are very very low today she's reminding
others to keep those hand sanitizers
close by
and practice social distance if possible
because the new variants like the delta
is highly contagious we in the united
states i think are pretty
uh fortunate that we have the
availability of vaccine and we have
healthcare resources but but even so we
want to be cautious and
and use the resources at our disposal
christian casa is 8 news now